I
we're here with former US Women's
Championship women's grandmaster Russa
dongle tiani Russa welcome back to st.
Louis what are your thoughts going into
this tournament well I'm just going to
take one game at a time and try to enjoy
the tournament I don't really have
anything any big plans ahead of their
time and I know you've got a family and
you're in school is it getting harder to
balance time or are you getting better
at balance in the time now that you have
been down this road before it is a
little bit harder now because I
transferred to columbia university and
the workload is a lot more demanding
than it was in my previous college but i
enjoy it i enjoy it all I think it's
great to have kids and study and play
chess so far I'm managing and as far as
this tournament there's a couple things
going on you're actually playing for the
title of course but you're also trying
to boost your rating for possible
Olympiad invitation as that thought
crossed your mind oh sure again I feel
like you know if I think about a limpet
and other things I won't be able to
perform as well but definitely I've had
great times at Olympiad I've always done
well and I really hope to call if I if
I'm lucky I guess I will what kinds of
things do you like to do in st. Louis in
between the rounds well I like to hang
out with my friends because I don't
really get to see them as often so I
think it's great to see them again and
we just hang out and try to relax in
between games you like that the women's
and men's fields are about equal number
now um yeah I think it's good i mean i
understand that there are a lot more men
playing chess so it would be you know
okay to have more more men play but i
think it's nice that it's small because
everybody gets to um I don't know I
enjoy each other's company n do you get
to talk to everyone do you know of any
other National Women's Championship
anywhere in the world with a prize fund
as high as this one
sixty-four-thousand-dollar no I really
don't i think it's the best you
I mean best Nationals and best place to
play chess in the whole world and in
this tournament you're going to have
nine rounds so let me give you a
hypothetical would you rather have five
white sand for blacks the would rather
have four whites but the four whites
come against the four highest rated
women well I don't really care as long
as I play well are we gonna still see
some Kings Indians from you baby I don't
want to give what your preparation but
thanks to your time Lisa very welcome